Hey, Charles.
>> Hey, Michael.
How's it going?
>> How are you doing, Charles?
>> I'm doing great.
Guess who stopped by
the studio this morning?
>> Our T.A. from last year?
>> Yes, Pushkar stopped by, and he
brought me ice cream which I am eating.
>> Good for you.
>> Mm-hm, just like old times.
>> All the times.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Not just the old times.
>> And that's fair.
So what are we going
to talk about today.
>> Well actually kind of in that same
vain this sort of idea that every time
that we record,
push cart seems Fair, that's fair.
So what are we going to
talk about today?
>> Well,
actually kind of in that same vein.
The sort of idea that
every time that we record,
push cart seems to bring you ice cream
is an example of generalization.
>> Well done.
>> Thanks,
I can make predictions about what might
happen next time we record together
based on generalizing from the past
times that we've been together.
Even though it's kind
of a different state.
And so, the idea of generalization
is going to be to leveraged
learning in states where
we've been to try to
make predictions about states where we
haven't been or haven't been very often.
>> Well that sounds interesting so this
will allow us to teach Xs how to swim
for example looking at your pictures.
>> You don't like my pictures.
The idea of the picture here is
that we've got actual data points
these five Xs.
But then we use this notion
of generalization to kind of
make predictions at places
where we don't have data.
>> So it's machine learning.
>> Yes, actually, very good point.
>> Cool.
All right.
Well, I look forward to it.
>> So
this is the machine learning part, or
the generalization part of
reinforcement learning.
>> Excellent.